so we're in Iceland and there's a very
specific reason we came here we're
searching for a very peculiar feeling
but it's a feeling that you recognize
instantly when you feel it it's inspired
by the line you have to go there to know
there so that's what we're doing right
now we're looking to the place to give
birth to an interior experience because
I believe that there is a circular
relationship between the spaces that
surround us and the worlds they give
rise to inside of our minds now most of
the time we walk around with a thick
skin
we're shielding ourselves from the world
the world is usually a scary place it's
unpredictable and there's hostility and
people are out to get us or it's tedious
and it's boring and it robs us of our
passions and saps us of our vitality and
so it's no surprise we close ourselves
off it's no surprise that we shy away
from life we want to feel less not more
because everything we're normally
feeling is an existential bummer most of
the time so therein lies the problem
because then you see a postcard you see
a brochure of a beautiful place and for
a for a moment for an instant you
imagine hmm Wow this feeling that I'm
having this feeling yeah just leave it
like that
um this feeling that is evoked by the
place is a very is a very instantly
recognizable feeling you remember it
from those endless summer days of your
childhood and so you see the brochure
you see the postcard and you decide I'm
gonna take the trip to that place but
then you might get to that place and
you're still thick-skinned right because
you bring in yourself along for the ride
and that's
problem and myself I mean the inner
chatter the monkey mind the trauma the
negativity the baggage but if
you're able to shatter that self to
crack yourself open right to to blast
new tunnels between the mind and the
other to become what you behold to see
the world like a child with a virginal
sense of heightened qualitative
intensity and awareness and engagement
then my friends the world will imprint
itself on you qualities of this place
will colonize your mind like a kind of
inverse PTSD and that experience of
inverse PTSD will perform wonders for
your psyche it's like an open-heart
surgery of your psyche so this is really
the art of the pilgrimage it's the art
of the religious undertaking it's a
journey that is at once outer but also
inner and so that's where I'm at right
now with my dear brother Jordan trying
to communicate trying to share trying to
convey transmit a glimpse and intimation
of what this experience is doing to me
and I hope it's I hope it's giving you
tickles in your stomach and and the kind
of excitability mixed with anxiety that
comes right before the beginning of a
great journey my hope is through this
kind of content you are inspired to take
a journey of your own to the places and
spaces beyond imagination and beyond the
everyday that's why we travel and that's
my invitation to you